[Music]
thank you so much for being here uh
okay last night
this debate and uh happens it's town
hall style debates for undecided voters
okay first thing i want to ask you about
and the media is talking about it a lot
i think a lot of people noticed it there
was a level of what seemed like anger
last night these two guys because it was
a town hall format they could prowl the
stage they got close there was a couple
times where i thought someone's going to
throw a punch yeah which would have been
amazing great ratings gold really yeah
coders to the polls a kung fu fight had
broken out that would have been
fantastic um were you surprised by that
the the tone the level of animosity
it was kind of political
two men enter one man leave you expected
i i was expecting to see hair extensions
and fake nails on the on the floor
didn't have a little bit of that reality
show feel when they start to go after
each other it was kardashian-esque i
mean there was a lot of
listen i'll say this we know that
democrats and republicans don't like
each other these days but mitt romney
and barack obama really don't like each
other i mean beyond i think party
sentiment these are two guys
that i don't think really respect each
other um and for that reason
there was a lot of i would say energy
masculine energy in the room but it did
have this sort of siegfried and roy
feeling where a bengali tiger like might
have come out and just you know nail oh
my god
it was intense no even at the end of
this even at the end of the debate it
was like you you saw the body language
between the two men and there was almost
a magnetic force field around each one
of them there was no kind of getting
close to one there was one point where
the president and governor romney one
was finished i think
the president was finished with a
question and was walking this way mitt
romney coming that way and their
shoulders missed by like the slightest
bit and for a second i thought it's
going to be like a shoulder hit
and then
and then it's all hearing the stands
would have been fantastic at one point
you know you could have the tension was
so thick that obama couldn't just come
up over romney's shoulder and said
boo and it would have just and he would
have lost anything yeah the door and the
floor would open i don't know it was it
was intense okay everyone immediately
trying to decide who's the winner i find
a little bit of that that a little bit
maddening no one can quite figure out
i've seen polls that say that many polls
are saying that they think that
president obama came out ahead other
polls say when you break it down people
may feel that governor romney might do a
better job of the economy
yeah i mean look
there are two things to say one i
thought the president won actually i
mean i thought he the bar was quite low
for him given that he was catatonic they
call it the great xanax debate of 2012
the first one after the first debate he
you know some people are saying all he
has to do is show up at the second one
wearing pants and he's going to win this
game
he's going to maybe come in boxers and
the bar was that low um
i thought he was really i thought he was
really strong last night and for that
reason came away as the winner but to
your point about the polls i mean we are
now parsing a part of the electorate
that is so narrow i'm not sure that like
rasmussen and reuters aren't calling the
same dude sitting in front of his tv
like what about today and he's like okay
romney and then on wednesday they call
him and he's like i think obama i mean
it's literally just a handful of voters
and here's what's making me crazy as a
viewer i don't know how everybody else
feels about this but but when you're
watching the debate and they're tracking
people's opinions as you're watching it
and you know the the the lines are going
up and down that just feels like madness
to me and i've noticed usually the line
just goes up when someone starts to
speak yes because that goes down when
they're not speaking and then they start
to speak and it goes up
and then it goes down again when they
stop speaking and i think now we're just
polling people's ability to tell when
someone's talking
i like words words are good words oh
it's quiet again and i'm not gonna vote
for quiet yeah sound sound stimulus a
bouncing ball i would rather know what
they're thinking and i bet it's
something along the lines of should i
have another cookie maybe i'll have
another cookie what about a beer is that
romney who is that guy you know i that's
what i'm thinking the whole time you
know look only certain channels do our
channel doesn't actually do that kind of
focus grouping so you don't do you do we
do not do that live kind of this is the
you know the sort of seismic shift going
on in someone's head during a debate
because i think with all this stuff it
takes a minute for
the cement to harden especially in a
debate last like last night i mean the
first one was such a clear kind of a
clear-cut loss for the president it
didn't take that long but on this one i
think it's a little bit it's gelling a
little bit slower we don't know